Beyonce and Rihanna yep together in one
room plus only we've got a behind the
scenes look at Kingsman the Golden
Circle
happy Friday you guys we've got those
new music Friday picks for you later
plus I'm giving away and Amy's gift back
so you might want to stick around but
first Beyonce had a busy night in New
York City last night don't know who's
watching those babies but it all started
when B hit up a Broadway show she graced
her presence at dear Evan Hanson
surprising the cast backstage after
their performance
Beyonce shared this moment with the
show's lead Tony winner Ben Platt who
tweeted this happened needless to say
the cast was very shook in fact here's a
video of the aftermath of that moment
[Music]
they're so not okay but dear Evan Hanson
meeting Beyonce is all of us meeting
Beyonce now a rep for the show says
Queen B came backstage and was basically
still crying and told them how much she
loved the show as she was leaving she
said god bless you guys and someone in
the cast shouted back god bless you and
amen to that now from Broadway to the
ball Beyonce then jetted off to
Rihanna's diamond ball which raised five
million dollars for her Clara Lionel
Foundation it also marked the first
official date night for Beyonce and
jay-z since the birth of their twins now
the 36 year old wore a hundred and sixty
five dollar teal wrapped maxi dress and
of course being RiRi snapped a pic
together at their table now their
friendship goes way back after all Jay
was Rihanna's mentor and was part of the
song that launched her career
this is your tenth year for umbrella
it's the tenth anniversary of that video
that changed the game for you do what do
you remember from that time I remember
the UK blaming me for the rainiest
Summer of in history
JIT remember that they said every week
that it was number one they had rain and
I I couldn't take the blame I was happy
with the number one all right well
moving on to a movie you can expect to
be number one in the box office
Kingsman the Golden Circle there's even
more elaborate stunts going on in this
sequel and only we can take you behind
the scenes with new players Channing
Tatum and Halle Berry
[Music]
it's cool it's 5e it's hip it's edgy but
it's got that feeling of espionage and
spine let's get started
colles a brainy scientist in the action
packed sequel about a super-secret
British spy agency welcome to state
channing is a hotshot american secret
agent when they work together it was
quite the band boy the first thing i
think i said just because i was nervous
and she's so beautiful okay wouldn't you
know i'm saying do you think you're the
most used name in rap songs
yeah that was my introduction to tanning
on his movie i loved the first king's
men so i'm so stoked for this one and
plus there are so many people in it
including Julianne Moore and Jeff
Bridges that hits theaters September
22nd all right it's time to get into our
new music Friday playlist
starting with Nick Jonas who just
dropped his new single find you here's
what Nick told et was the inspiration
for his latest banger took the house
beat and put Popular's to it and I
talked about this this stage of my life
I'm in where you know I think it's about
discovering who you are as much as it is
about looking for love and everything
else and understanding that you don't
have it all figured out but it's okay to
kind of be a little bit on the journey
speaking of journey we have been waiting
what feels like a lifetime for some new
Sara Bareilles and we finally got a new
track from the songbird in the form of
if I dare her new single from the battle
of the sexes soundtrack
[Music]
[Applause]
use your little scribes I don't
[Music]
don't be a little bit of a slow jam
there for you guys today I know I
changed it up a little bit on um but
finally wait until you hear the remix of
Lords homemade dynamite no pun intended
but it is fired
it features Khalid post Malone and
scissor
[Music]
[Music]
I sent your friend to the store it's
only me
finally is doing not don't quit drinking
its liquor there's so much more than
that song you guys have to go check that
out
homemade dynamite remix thank you lord
alright before we head out there is a
little of that happening this weekend
called the Emmy Awards I've heard of it
TV's biggest night is in the hands of
Stephen Colbert who is hosting and et's
nischelle Turner talked to Colbert at
the official red carpet roll out the
Late Show funny man who's also nominated
has plenty to look forward to that night
who should be afraid in the audience who
should be afraid yes no one no one
should be afraid to play nice everyone
everyone we're all gonna be very nice to
each other be afraid of what they might
impale themselves on Emmys Wings what do
you mean afraid and sometimes those
folks in the front row they get it yeah
yeah yeah Reese Witherspoon has it
coming
ok I'm coming for your Reese don't worry
guys Reese who is also presenting will
at least walk away with this epic Emmys
give back and now you can too tinder for
your chance to win head over to ET
online.com slash giveaways you must be
18 and over and you have until midnight
on Monday to enter so good luck
alright the Emmys air this Sunday
September 17th live on both coasts at
8:00 p.m. Eastern and 5 p.m. Pacific to
watch the show live tune in to CBS on TV
or stream on CBS all access to I get all
the CBS love in I think I did all right
be sure to keep it locked to e t--'s
facebook page after the Emmys on Sunday
for a complete breakdown of the night's
biggest moments and again on Monday
morning for a look at the best and worst
fashion moments from the red carpet I
will be there and I will have your
inside look at what it's really like
on the Emmys red carpet I'll have that
for you guys Monday on the daily denne
so I will see you then enjoy your
weekend I'm gonna go rest